y meter el chorro fondo en pocos días
más se va a llevar a cabo el segundo
foro hispano sobre violencia conyugal
puede darnos algunos detalles al
respecto
sí claro que sí louis muchas gracias por
esta invitación estamos muy
entusiasmados de poder producir este
evento por segunda ocasión ya está está
este año en esta edición vamos a hacerlo
enteramente digital puesto que no fue
permitido organizar un evento presencial
pero eso nos dio la oportunidad también
de traerle al público una una propuesta
una refrescada sobre lo que es el
fenómeno de la violencia conyugal
adaptado a la realidad que actualmente
estamos viviendo así como diferentes
manifestaciones artísticas donde se
trata como tema la violencia conyugal es
la información que ustedes enviaron
sobre este evento se dice que la
violencia de la violencia conyugal
perdón es una realidad en quebec aún hoy
en nuestros días de qué manera
bueno en realidad esto es una
problemática muy real en esta provincia
este vemos con regularidad casos muy
sonados
en los medias de masas donde vemos
lamentablemente episodios de violencia
entre cónyuges que tienen un desenlace
trágico muchas veces las víctimas no
solamente incluyen a las esposas o en
ciertos casos más raros los esposos pero
también a los hijos lamentablemente en
los servicios de policía y de casas de
albergue que están tomando una medición
de estos sucesos han observado un
aumento de los casos que han sido
llamémoslo así reportados o declarados a
causa del confinamiento en realidad es
nuestro propósito desde el propósito de
nuestro foro es de poder analizar cuáles
son las causas de este fenómeno que se
está dando así como hacerles conocer a
la población hispana de que ve
recursos que están disponibles
actualmente
ustedes también decían en la gacetilla
que nos ha llegado que en el caso de la
comunidad inmigrante en general en el
caso suyo hispana en particular por los
inmigrantes en general viven además el
tema de la violencia conyugal como un
crimen un fenómeno que puede agravar la
situación de
dificultades que pueda vivir cualquier
persona que decida a afincarse en una
sociedad nueva si de hecho lo que lo que
se ha observado es de que la violencia
conyugal en realidad
en lo que son familias o parejas
inmigrantes viene a vulnerar todavía más
la situación que estas personas están
viviendo por sus procesos migratorios de
hecho la segunda parte de la jornada
vamos a tener un panel donde estaremos
contando con la presencia de una abogada
en inmigración también tendremos una
abogada en derecho familiar y en
personas que trabajan en a nivel de los
servicios socio comunitarios que nos van
a poder justamente ilustrar con casos
concretos cómo es el fenómeno se
desarrolla de hecho lo que sucede
específicamente entre las familias de
inmigrantes
son varias cosas primeramente la digamos
el no conocimiento de la lengua francesa
hace de que muchas víctimas dudan en
delatar oa llamar a las autoridades para
pedir ayuda eso hace que tienen acceso
menos acceso a los servicios además de
eso si las víctimas se encuentran en un
proceso migratorio como por ejemplo un
proceso de apadrinamiento muchas veces
son este amenazadas por los victimarios
diciéndoles que si ellas delatan la
agresión pues que ellos mismos van a
poder parar el proceso migratorio y van
a asegurarse que las víctimas se hace
así como los hijos sean deportados
entonces eso causa un factor de miedo en
las víctimas y es por eso es que los
casos todavía son a todavía menos
reportados entre las familias
inmigrantes
usted hablaba hace unos instantes de la
pandemia y de que la misma ha venido a
grabar el fenómeno de la violencia
conyugal tiene algún ejemplo concreto
alguna explicación específica para
darnos si claro existen varios factores
agravantes que fueron introducidos con
lo de la pandemia y primeramente fue que
el lado el tema digamos del
confinamiento vino a hacer que muchos de
los victimarios podemos decir se
encuentran todavía más presentes en la
casa eso hace que digamos las dinámicas
de control que ellos emplean con sus
víctimas sean todavía más contundentes y
más agresivas además de eso está el
aspecto de que el confinamiento vino
también a traer un impacto en la salud
mental de las personas causando niveles
altos de estrés y de ansiedad lo que
puede detonar en episodios de violencia
y si a eso le agregamos también
las condiciones precarias económicas en
las que nos estamos enfrentando pues eso
también hace que se induce todavía más
un factor un factor estresante de
llamémoslo así en el seno familiar se
dice frecuentemente que la reticencia
por parte de las víctimas a denunciar
este tipo de hechos es una de las
razones principales por las cuales se
carece de mayor información de tipo
estadístico sobre la realidad concreta
de la audiencia conyugal en el caso
específico de quebec o de canadá en
general es esto así es solamente la
reticencia de las víctimas o falta tal
vez de alguna actitud más precisamente
activa de parte de las autoridades y de
los organismos responsables para
contrarrestar este fenómeno si tienes
mucha razón visión lo que tú estás
diciendo realmente observamos que existe
obviamente la reticencia de las víctimas
a justamente a llevar estos casos a las
autoridades pero también en en ciertas
comunidades quizás no necesariamente la
hispana en particular pero otras
comunidades donde digamos las
autoridades si podemos llamarla
religiosas adentro de las comunidades
culturales tienen una incidencia en la
gestión de asuntos familiares muchas
víctimas se sienten presionadas por sus
mismas comunidades a no delatar en otras
palabras a que la los trapos sucios se
lavan en casa muchas de estas víctimas
de hecho lo que ha sucedido es de que
una vez ellas han llevado un caso a las
autoridades son rechazadas por sus
propias comunidades entonces hay una
dimensión social también que
lamentablemente es un es un factor
desfavorable y por eso todas las
estadísticas que en este momento podemos
encontrar en términos de la violencia
conyugal siempre se explica que estos
son realmente
basadas en los informes oficiales pero
que es hay muchos casos no oficiales o
que no han sido declarados que están
manifestándose me decía usted hace un
par de minutos que el desconocimiento de
la lengua se puede convertir en una
barrera a la hora de denunciar que esta
situación no solamente denunciar de
pedir ayuda también cuentan en el caso
específico de la comunidad hispana a sus
integrantes con información necesaria y
suficiente para saber a quién pueden
recurrir a dónde deben recurrir bueno en
este caso luís han habido avances en el
tema por ejemplo aquí a nivel de quebec
se ha establecido un servicio que es una
línea de escucha que se llama psoe se
violan conyugal que es llegar digamos la
línea telefónica de primera línea donde
toda víctima puede llamar y éste exponer
su caso actualmente eso es violación
conyugal ofrece sus servicios únicamente
en francés
es más sin embargo ellos ya comenzaron a
concientizarse sobre la realidad
cultural y lingüística de nuestra ciudad
y ya ellos tienen traducido sus
documentos en diferentes lenguas existen
por otra parte a nivel digamos de los
servicios comunitarios algunas casas de
albergue para mujeres y familias
violentadas que ya tienen personal de
habla hispana de hecho uno de nuestros
panelistas va a ser la señora cecilia
ivonne escamilla del centro de ayuda
para familias latinoamericanas carla que
ellos han instalado una línea de escucha
en español para nuestras familias
entonces esperamos que estas iniciativas
se multipliquen y puedan crecer para que
nuestra comunidad tenga más acceso a
estos recursos por último recuerde nos
por favor cuando se va a llevar a cabo
en esta segunda este segundo foro y de
qué manera pueden participar aquellos
que estén interesados en hacerlo
sí claro que sí nuestro foro se va a
llevar a cabo el día sábado 19 de
diciembre de nueve de la mañana a cinco
de la tarde
va a haber una programación en todo el
día va a ser transmitida vida la página
facebook y el canal de youtube de la
casa de las américas un mes donde es de
américa y también pues para todos
aquellos interesados en participar es
importante mencionar que el costo de
admisión es gratuito y pueden simple y
sencillamente responder al evento
facebook que lo tenemos circulando para
pues estar al tanto de los enlaces de
conexión ese día y el chorro fondo
muchas gracias por esta entrevista con
el rollo que nos da internacional
gracias a ti louis